the senate judiciary committee is set
for a more intense day of confirmation
hearings for supreme court nominee amy
coney barrett
the appeals court judge laid out her
conservative approach to the law
yesterday in her opening statement
republicans praised her credentials
while democrats called the hearings
a sham and predicted that barrett would
lead the high court in a radical new
direction
nancy cordes is covering the hearings on
capitol hill for us nancy good morning
to you
what's happening today good morning well
today is round
one of questioning and each of the 22
senators
on the committee will get a half an hour
to grill judge barrett so she could be
on the hot seat
for more than 11 hours today before a
follow-up round tomorrow
fielding tough questions about abortion
the election and obamacare
so help you god today's endurance test
will pit
judge barrett against 10 senate
democrats who regard her nomination
as an illegitimate power grab by the
president and his party
i think this hearing is a sham with
remarkable
unity democrats made it clear yesterday
they plan to focus
on the roughly 20 million americans who
could lose coverage
if a 6-3 supreme court overturns
obamacare for years merritt put off
going to the doctor because he
was like many americans afraid he could
not afford it
but when the affordable care act was
passed he finally got the coverage he
could afford
the committee's 12 republicans will be
far friendlier
i think you're a great choice by the
president yesterday they praised
barrett's resume her temperament
and her conservative judicial philosophy
you are a brilliant jurist
and a constitutional law expert
barrett does have some experience with
this she fielded questions from the same
committee during her federal appeals
court confirmation
in 2017. when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you there would be no
opportunity to be a
no vote on roe and as i said to the
committee i would faithfully apply all
supreme court precedent
republicans warned democrats not to
bring up barrett's faith
this time when you tell somebody that
they're too catholic to be on the bench
when you tell them they're going to be a
catholic judge not an american judge
that's bigotry
thank you very much the ongoing pandemic
looms over this hearing
utah's mike lee who tested positive
after barrett's rose garden ceremony
last month
appeared in person yesterday removing
his mask to speak
senator ted cruz who was exposed to lee
appeared remotely
as did democratic vp nominee kamala
harris who did so as a precaution
this committee has ignored common sense
requests to keep
people safe including not requiring
testing for all members
despite a coronavirus outbreak among
senators of this very committee
democrats have made it clear that
they're going to steer clear
of questioning judge barrett about her
religion this time around plus they
think
that obamacare health care more broadly
is the best focus it was the number one
issue to voters back in 2018 they think
it's going to be a big issue
in 2020. as far as republicans are
concerned they are still hoping anthony
that they can get this judge confirmed
to the supreme court
one week before election day all right
nancy it's going to be close